hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2002 american science fiction and
thriller movie called clock stoppers
the movie begins in an airport where a
bearded man is in a rush it seems like
he is being chased by someone to make
things worse the ticket for the most
recent flight is fully booked he then
keeps moving until he finds a man who is
willing to give his ticket after he
gives him a lot of money
unfortunately as soon as he reaches the
plane suddenly he is pulled out of the
airport into a van rapidly two agents
appear out of nowhere taking off his
disguise
the scene then moves to a teenager named
zach who rides his bicycle to the
antique store
he steals an old vintage typewriter and
tries to sell it to ebay for a higher
price
turns out that he is dying to buy a new
car
meanwhile his dad george gibbs is a
quantum physics lecturer in the
university
zack meets his dad begging him to sign a
co-letter for the new car but george
postponed it since he has been very busy
recently working on a project at qt lab
with his student earl doppler
disappointed zack then visits his best
friend meeker who works in a paintball
gun store
he invites zach to attend a dj contest
which he signed up to
zach spots francesca the hot girl that
just enrolled in his school and attempts
to start a conversation with her
but francesca is not interested in him
zack then returns home where he begs his
dad to come with him to the car showroom
however george chooses to work on his
project since doppler has been missing
for a week and it must be finished
before the conference in the following
week ignoring his son's request for now
that night george is seen just finishing
the most technologically advanced watch
and stores it in a secret box
on the other side mr gates ceo of qt
company is seen talking to agent moore
who informs him that he is shutting down
his ongoing black ops project due to the
risk of the technology being misused by
hostile powers the man warns him that
his men will come back in the following
week to collect all the research
equipment the bearded man who turns out
to be the missing doctor doppler but in
an older form is actually gate scientist
and he is forced to create a machine
called molecular stabilizer in hypertime
state a state where people can move at a
very fast pace it is then revealed that
he looks much older because he has been
working for too long in the hypertime he
reveals that he has been working with
george to solve this aging problem which
makes gates furious since it is a very
classified project
back at the house zach's sister
accidentally knocks the watch out of its
box
not long after sac finds the watch and
decides to wear it to school upon
arrival he sees francesca is being
teased by two men and decides to
approach her intending to help her
however he gets humiliated by them
instead
luckily she sees his effort and she
finally is willing to give him her
address inviting him to come over
after school he immediately heads over
to the hot girl's house where he is told
to help her rake leaves
although he is a bit disappointed
because it is not what he's expecting he
tries to stay positive and agrees to
help her at some point he accidentally
presses a button in the watch which
suddenly slows every movement around him
he brings a huge mouse into the house
and everything suddenly becomes normal
again which makes francesca shocked
he then realizes that he actually
activates the hypertime state he then
shows what he just discovered to the
girl who also gets into the hypertime
he then remembers that the watch is
actually accelerating their molecules
making them move very fast that's why
everything around seems like it is
moving very slowly
with a watch sack eventually wins
francesca's heart they use the watch's
power for fun messing around in the city
they punish an officer who keeps sending
people parking tickets after that they
prank his school friends who like to
bully and a guy who promised to hold his
long awaited car for 24 hours
later that night the couple attended dj
contest where meeker is competing turns
out that meeker is still an amateur and
is mixing the music poorly causing the
crown to boom
zach and francesca decide to get into
the hypertime state and help their poor
friend with his friends help in
hypertime meeker suddenly becomes very
energetic and entertaining in the real
world which makes the rival confused
after the contest meeker still doesn't
have a single clue about what happened
to him they then drive him home and
francesca eventually give zach a good
night kiss just before he leaves he gets
into the hypertime and heads home where
he discovers that someone is breaking
into his house
gates and the henchman spot zack attempt
to shoot him with a liquid nitrogen but
he manages to dodge it and runs for his
life
luckily he is saved by dr doppler and
they drive away with a stolen van
a chase sequence in the hypertime state
ensues where doppler explains that
liquid nitrogen is used to slow down the
molecular activity after freeing himself
from cuff doppler forces zach to hand
over the watch but he refuses to do so
zack throws him off the van and
accidentally crashes the car into a
river
unfortunately the watch is broken as it
touches the water
the next day zach wakes up in the
hospital and tries to explain about the
watch and the pursuit to his family
after being accused of stealing a van
he then discovers that the henchmen are
still going after him he is able to dry
up the broken watch and successfully
dodges them after switching clothes with
one of the police officers on the other
side gates learns that george is zack's
father and doppler's secret colleague in
the project he then plans to kidnap the
father
zach asks meeker's help to borrow his
car but fails
thus he sneaks into francesca's huge
mansion to borrow clothes and a car to
find his dad who is attending a
conference
she lends him her bmw and decides to
come with him
meanwhile gate single-handedly
approaches george forcing him to finish
the molecular stabilizer in qt's lab
not long after zach and francesca arrive
at his dad's hotel room but cannot find
anyone there
he suspects that george has checked out
from the room while looking for his
father zack learns that he and dr
doppler are now becoming fbi fugitives
as soon as they leave the hotel a
garbage truck approaches them and
captures them a few moments later turns
out that dr doppler is the one who
kidnapped them francesca spontaneously
kicks him in his face
he then urges zach to hand over the
watch he refuses and the girl kicks him
again in his balls
they bring him to a motel where zach
interrogates him thinking that he is a
spy because doppler is not supposed to
be that old since he is georgia's
student in university
zack threatens to send doppler back to
qt if he does not want to help him
rescue george
doppler then reluctantly complies and
helps him to fix the watch
they sneak into the conference where
francesca distracts the nerds while the
boys steal required materials for the
watch
using a building drawn by doppler they
decide to break in through the
ventilation
at that point doppler finishes the brand
new watch
after that they visit meeker's store
where they create frozen hydrogen
bullets and borrow paintball weapons
that will be used to slow down their
foes sending them back to the normal
state the next day they sneak into the
building through the ventilation where
doppler decides not to go further since
he's got ptsd and is too afraid of being
captured again they get into the
hypertime state and managed to get
inside the building but a hypertime
alarm is triggered using their modified
weapons francesca and zach managed to
knock out several guards until they get
caught by gates henchmen the two are
thrown in a cell with george who is
trying to finish the machine
george scolds his son for trying to help
him but then they reconcile
outside the building agent moore arrives
at the building with his men to
confiscate the research equipment at the
same time george successfully finishes
the machine and gates immediately orders
him to test the molecular stabilizer he
activates the machine taking everyone in
the room into hypertime the trio plan a
strategy to escape from the cell
using the watch zack accelerates while
in hypertime state and reaches the speed
of light this light form allows him to
go through objects including the cells
wall
however he gets hit by the liquid
nitrogen and transforms back to his
normal form
george and francesca managed to create
an explosion and break free from the
cell
surviving from the explosion gates
manages to knock francesca out of
hypertime and prepares to fire the
liquid nitrogen to the others luckily
doppler arrives on time and shoots him
sending him back to normal state all
qt's employees are arrested by agent
moore while all the watches are being
taken
doppler uses the machine to reverse his
aging effect of hypertime transforming
him back to the teenager form the family
reunite and zach finally gets the car he
has been dreaming of as zach doppler
francesca and zack's sister drive away
it is revealed that he still keeps the
watch and they enter the hypertime state
together
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching